stream is live now let's make sure it
comes up
great stream is live all right welcome
to week four
the weeks are going by pretty fast here
um i don't know about the rest of you
but i know i complain a lot about
teaching
tuesday thursday and how it's harder
than teaching monday wednesday friday
but one kind of nice thing about it is
that
every class feels like an event so it
feels like a special occasion
especially tuesdays because i haven't
seen you in so long so
it's good to see you again welcome back
and let's jump in
so um today you know
i thought we were going to be done with
shandylandport we talked about it quite
a lot last time and i thought we were
not going to be talking about it anymore
but
then some people asked some really good
questions
uh over over the weekend
and then just by complete coincidence i
got an email
from somebody uh over the weekend who
was asking questions about one of my
older chandelier port videos and that
kind of just made me think that
this stuff just wasn't well enough
explained yet so
uh i think we're going to do a little
bit more discussion of candy lampport no
more than 10 minutes
to answer some leftover questions that
people have
about the chandelier import snapshot
algorithm
so this will be no more than 10 minutes
whoops not greater than less than or
equal to 10 minutes
um and then we're going to move on so i
want to talk about
safety and liveness
which are things that we've kind of
touched on already but we haven't really
uh formalized our discussion of them so
we're going to talk about safety and
liveness
and this is going to be our lead-in to
kind of a new section of the course
where we're going to be talking
about fault tolerance so today we're
going to kind of begin our discussion of
fault tolerance
very exciting and and the channel report
stuff kind of leads into that because if
you recall
um last time we talked about
assumptions that the chandelier snapshot
algorithm makes right we talked about
how it assumes that messages get
delivered
for example we assumed eventual delivery
um so that's going to be something that
falls
into our discussion of fault tolerance
so we're going to talk about reliable
delivery today
and then we're going to talk about
classifying
kinds of faults
and fault models
um and i hope that we have time to get
to the two generals problem today
so that's what we have on our plate for
today
all right so let's get to the chandylan
port stuff uh so
there was there there were a couple of
questions that i would like to try to
touch on
so one of them one of them was this
so i think there was a little bit of
confusion about the notion of channels
um so channels
uh in shandylandport we assume that
everybody has
a channel to everybody else
in other words we assume that every
process can send messages to everyone
else
in a fifo manner so
that might not be realistic for example
you might have let's say you have three
processes
and i'll just draw a little picture here
um of the the network topology so maybe
process one
and process two can communicate with
each other
and process two and process three can
and process three and process
one can so maybe it's something like
that um but in this case
um actually let's say that this
connection wasn't there
so let's say that process one and
process three can't directly communicate
with each other
they can communicate through this other
process process too
but that's it so
we just claimed that every process has a
channel to everyone else well
in chandi landport the assumption is
that
this this graph which we could call the
network topology or the communication
graph
the graph needs to be strongly connected
now this doesn't mean that it has to be
a complete graph
so it doesn't have to be the case that
um that all of these connections
exist if we can simulate that so in
other words if process one needs to talk
to process three
they can do it by simulating those
messages by passing a message to process
two here and saying
this actually isn't a message for you
it's a message for process three
so you could fake having this arrow here
by just going this way
and telling process two to forward the
message along
um and likewise uh in the other
direction
um so as long as your graph is strongly
connected
you can you can stimulate
having a complete graph
where complete just means that everybody
is connected to everybody else
so this needs to be the case in order
for the algorithm to work so chandy and
lanport say
in their paper if the communication
graph is strongly connected
then we know that everybody know
assuming reliable
delivery then we know that everybody is
going to record their state because
everybody's going to get
a marker message sooner or later
um but i think there was a little bit of
confusion about this
this fact i think maybe people were
thinking that
uh a channel is something that's set up
by sending a message through it or
something but
you shouldn't think of a channel that
way a channel is like a road
uh that cars may or may not drive on but
the road exists whether or not the cars
are driving on it
any questions about that
okay and then i think the other question
that people had left over in our
chandelier port discussion had to do
with um
had to do with the difference between
what uh what gets captured in the in the
process state and what gets captured in
the channel state so
a snapshot kind of consists of two
things
right so what is a snapshot really
well when we take a snapshot
of some execution
like if we've got some events here and
some messages here and we take a
snapshot at some point
then we're kind of capturing two things
we're capturing
the events that occurred which which
consist of the process state
or i should say the process date
consists of the events that have
occurred on every
every process but the snapshot also
captures something else it also captures
channel state so in this case if we had
p1 and p2
um p1 was recording messages on its
incoming channel
which was c21 and then there wasn't any
thing to record on c21 so that
um that channel state ended up being
empty um
and let's say that process two uh was
recording its channel state
um uh so on its incoming channel uh
which is c12
and let's say that this message right
here call it
m1 uh got recorded
uh in process whose channel state what
that means
is that when you go to look at the
snapshot later
anything that's in the channel state
like this
should be thought of as an in-transit
message
so the snapshot consists of you know
these events we can give them names
a and b on process one and c and d on
process two
and then also this extra piece of
information that there was an intransit
message
from process one to process two
why do you think it's important to
capture this sort of thing
uh somebody just asked we're assuming
that channels are fifo
right that's correct um yeah so
intrinsic in the definition of a channel
is this notion that it's that it's fifo
that's what a channel is
so the question here is why would you
care
about capturing an intransit message if
i took a snapshot here and my snapshot
said that
a and b happened on process one and c
happened on process two
why why would you want to capture this
intransit message
somebody says uh you can debug better
well yeah um but let's try to make this
a little bit more concrete what's an
example
of some thing that might be in this
intransit message that you might care
about
well here's a classic example let's say
that these uh that there's this system
of um where there's a token and only one
process can have the token at a time
and maybe whoever has the token has the
maybe they have access to some resource
that only one process is supposed to be
able to access it once make
access to a file or they have a block on
something it doesn't really matter what
in any case let's say that there's one
token
and you really want it to be the case
that there's only one token
present at any time in the distributed
system
well let's say that this message message
one was a message
that process one was sending to process
two saying
i'm giving up the token here you can
have it
if we didn't capture that information in
the intransit message
then the snapshot would be pretty
confusing right because we'd look at
this snapshot and we'd see well
according to our captured state of
process 1 it doesn't have the token
and according to our captured state of
process 2 it doesn't have the token
either so the snapshot would be pretty
confusing because the token would have
seemed to disappear
so that's why it's important to also
capture these intrinsic messages in the
in the snapshot because
there could be some information that's
supposed to always be true
of the system and hence should be true
of any snapshot of the system
um so that's why the chandelier import
algorithm also
captures these in transit messages now
it's kind of interesting because
we know from the way that the algorithm
works
that if the snapshot let's say that that
p2 happened to initiate this snapshot so
maybe it sent its marker message right
here
uh and then the reason why this snapshot
got taken down here was because maybe p1
received the marker message right here
took its snapshot and then sent its uh
marker message back so
the algorithm didn't actually finish
until here
in other words the algorithm didn't
finish on process two
until after message one had already
arrived
i think this is what's confusing to some
people because
there's this period of time between when
a process snapshots its own state
and when the algorithm actually gets
done on that process
so in some sense it doesn't feel like
this message is in transit anymore
because
the algorithm actually can't terminate
until that message has
come through the channel but in terms of
the snapshot of somebody just going back
and looking at this snapshot
they don't know what happened later with
these marker messages and so on the
marker messages aren't part of the
snapshot they're
they're just something that the
algorithm uses to compute the snapshot
so if all i have coming to look at this
later
is this
i have this that by itself
isn't all that helpful so i also have
this extra piece of information
that m1 was in transit from process one
to process two at the time the snapshot
is taken and
if i know that then i can go use that
information to understand
oh okay if that message was in transit
um then i understand that process 2 is
supposed to have the token
so that's why we have to capture the
uh the channel state so hopefully that's
helpful
and if you have more questions about
this please ask because i don't want
this to be
unclear
okay
all right with that i think we're going
to move on
so our next topic
safety and liveness i'm excited to get
to this
all right so let's really quickly recap
um some of those delivery guarantees
that we talked about before
so you know we talked about fifo
delivery
which we know you know rules out things
like this
so things like this won't happen under
fifo delivery
and then we talked about causal delivery
which rules out things like this
and we talked about totally ordered
delivery
uh and so on um
and we talked about ways to enforce
these so we talked about enforcing fifo
delivery
using something like sequence numbers or
acknowledgements
we talked about enforcing causal
delivery in the particular case of
broadcast messages
uh using the causal broadcast algorithm
that we discussed
um we didn't yet talk about a way to um
to enforce total order delivery oh i
guess i'll draw my
little diagram here for totally ordered
delivery just so this picture is
complete
so we didn't yet talk about a way to
enforce this one but we talked about
what it is
so totally order delivery means you
don't have that
okay so we've been talking about all
these properties
fifo delivery causal delivery totally
ordered delivery
these are all specifications of
how a system should behave
and one thing that i want to convince
you of is that
these are all a particular kind of
property these all fall into the
category of what we call
safety properties
the safety property colloquially is a
property that tells you
that something bad won't happen
so these are all safety properties they
all say
there's a bad thing and the property
says the bad thing won't happen so these
pictures show the bad
thing that each of these safety
properties are ruling out
there's another kind of property and
it's a liveness property
so if a safety property says that a bad
thing won't happen what do you think the
aliveness property will say
good aliveness property
say that a good thing
will happen
have we talked about any liveness
properties yet can you think of any
liveness properties that we've discussed
even a little bit in this class
we certainly haven't discussed them to
the extent that we have discussed safety
properties
but they have come up a little bit
what do you think
wow pretty quiet
okay let me give an example of one
messages eventually get delivered
eventual delivery good
somebody put it in chat just as i was
writing it out
so that falls into this category of
liveness properties
a good thing will happen a big hint
if you're trying to figure out whether a
property is a safety property or
aliveness property
is this word eventually
and you can think of the word eventually
kind of implicitly being in here
so when we say say that a good thing
will happen it means say that a good
thing will eventually happen
sooner or later
so let's try to make it a little bit
more formal what the difference is
between safety properties and liveness
properties
uh in addition to just this sort of say
that a bad thing won't happen say that a
good thing will happen because that's a
little bit vague and i haven't
stated in any formal terms what bad and
good mean and i don't think i can
so let's try to formalize this a little
so safety properties
uh which are the ones that say that a
bad thing won't happen
safety properties are properties that
can
be violated
in a finite execution
in other words you can point to an
execution
i'll just take i'll take causal delivery
as an example
you can point to an execution and say
right there is where we went wrong right
there is where the bad thing happened
liveness properties on the other hand
so
cannot be violated in a finite execution
why not why do you think that is what
would happen
if i tried to draw a picture here of an
execution
that violates eventual delivery well
how would you do it right like
maybe you have a message
and the message hasn't arrived over here
yet
but it's not that the property has been
violated
it's just that it hasn't been satisfied
yet
so i'm going to write that down just so
it's obvious
so liveness properties are actually
tricky to reason about
because safety properties
it's more straightforward you can look
at an execution and say
oh this execution observes the safety
property
or violates the safety property a
liveness property is different
you can look at an execution and maybe
all the messages haven't been delivered
yet right
or maybe maybe the message arrived right
but it's cued right maybe it's stuck in
the delay queue
remember how with causal delivery causal
broadcast we talked about how there was
a delay queue
so messages arrive and they're queued
and they haven't come out of the queue
yet
but it doesn't mean that they're not
ever going to come out of the queue it
just means that they haven't yet
so i cannot draw a picture of a finite
execution that violates eventual
delivery it's not possible
because it's a liveness property
so
we can we know that a property is a
safety property if we can
point at something that violates it in a
finite execution
so all of those delivery properties that
we talked about earlier
fifo delivery causal delivery total
order delivery
they all count as safety properties
eventual delivery messages eventually
get delivered this is the first liveness
property i think that we've really
talked about
liveness properties are usually
considered much harder to reason about
but the trouble is you really need both
so why why is it so important like why
do you need both
what if i told you to implement fifo
delivery
and i said just just worry about the
safety property of fifo delivery
don't worry about any liveness
properties
what could you do
that's right yeah you could drop all the
messages on the floor
and it wouldn't violate fifo delivery so
what's needed there is a combination of
safety and liveness
that's right or you could just ignore
all the messages
on the receiving end so yeah what you
could do
is satisfy the safety property and you
could say look i duly satisfied
fifo delivery um what grade do i get i
deserve an a
um but liveness is something that we
care about for having systems that
actually work so
if i told you to just if you build a
system that that that just drops or
ignores every message and doesn't
deliver any
etc uh that satisfies
fifo delivery um so
safety by itself is pretty useless
now liveness by itself is also pretty
useless and we'll talk about that more
later on so
really what you want in any given system
is you want both a safety property and a
liveness property depending on the
system
so let me
define for you this eventual delivery
thing other than just
messages eventually get delivered
because
that's kind of a circular definition
let's give a little bit of a more formal
definition
i'm actually going to call it reliable
delivery
so here's one way to define reliable
i'll call this take one
because i think we might come back and
define it differently later but let's
try this
we'll say let p1 be a process
that sends a message
m to
[Music]
process p2
if neither p1 nor p2 crashes
then p2 eventually delivers
the message
so the reason i said this would just
take one of our definition was
because of this piece right here
so i think this piece might need a
little bit of finesse
and in particular we might need to add
some other conditions there
for example sometimes you'll see people
say something like
if neither p1 nor p2 crashes
and not all messages are lost
so this is kind of interesting right why
would it be that some people define this
differently
well that's going to lead into the topic
of fault models
and fault classification
which we're going to talk about next but
anyway i'm claiming that reliable
delivery
is a is a liveness ah somebody's asking
about this not all message is our last
thing here
well yeah so the question is if any
aren't delivered how is that reliable
um maybe this will become more clear
later after we talk about uh
about fault models um but
i'm trying to think of the best way to
answer your question um
so
we care about message m getting from p1
to p2
but it might take a few attempts right
there's nothing in here
that says that it couldn't take a few
attempts so
maybe to implement eventual delivery
p1 has to keep trying over and over
and maybe the first five attempts get
lost but if the sixth one
succeeds then the message has been
delivered and we're in good shape
so that's why we say not all messages
are lost here
if all the messages are lost then
there's no hope but if not all of them
are lost
then the message has a chance of getting
through
okay so why is this a liveness property
well it says that a good thing
eventually happens which is the eventual
delivery of of this message m
and we know that it can't be violated in
a finite execution
because
even if p1 is making lots of attempts
to deliver m and all those attempts are
failing
it doesn't mean that it's not going to
succeed on the next try
so i can't draw a picture of a finite
execution in which this reliable
delivery property is being violated
so that means that it can't be a safety
property
and every property it turns out is
either safety
or liveness or a combination of the two
so because it can't be safety it's got
to be liveness
questions about that
sometimes i advertise that the twitch
stream is starting on twitter before
class but today i didn't
so i think we have fewer people on
twitch today
here's a question what about if we were
in deadlock
then reliable delivery cannot occur
okay so in other words um
if process one can't
send messages because it's waiting on
something from process two
and i'm not sure if i understand the
question exactly
let's put that one on the stack for
later i'm not sure if i understand the
question about what if we were in
deadlock
uh somebody just asked will we dive
deeper into why every property is either
safety or liveness
that's a great question so
i don't think we're going to dive too
deeply into it but i can refer you to
some papers
for the moment i'm going to ask you to
take on faith that
all properties
are either safety
or liveness
or a combination
all right so we want to talk about fault
models and fault classification next so
let me try to set the stage for this
when you're designing a system you need
to start
by making certain assumptions about the
environment in which
that system will operate so in
particular
if you're trying to design a system that
will tolerate faults
like say processes crashing or messages
being lost
you you want to have some sort of an
idea in mind about what kind of faults
may occur
so that you know what kind of faults you
need to tolerate
so you need some way of classifying
faults or putting them in categories
so that brings us to this topic of fault
models
so a fault model
is something that tells you which
categories of faults can
can occur
so you know which ones you have to worry
about so if you think back to day one of
class
we talked about this scenario where we
have two machines
and machine one asks machine
2 a question
and hopes to get a response
and we talked about a bunch of different
ways in which this could go wrong
can somebody remind me of some of those
that we talked about before
okay the message was never received why
it could get lost in the network
it could be slow
what else
why might m1 not hear back
if you're m1 you're sitting here
you've sent this message out into the
either and you don't hear back what are
some of the other reasons why you might
not hear back
good m2 crashed
m2 is slow
um and what else the message
back from m1 m2 to m1 the response could
be slow
or it could get lost
um and then one that we kind of briefly
discussed
um two could lie
so let's try to classify these faults
into categories
so for this first one where a message
gets lost oh
we're going to call this an omission
fault so a message getting lost is an
omission fault
what about number two the message from
m1 being slow
well uh there are different choices for
what to call this
i'm going to call this one a timing
fault
uh what about number this next one here
m2 crashed what should we call that one
fault yeah that's what i would call it
and then we can kind of fill in the rest
here so this one also has to do with
slowness so that's another
timing fault
this is another timing fault
uh what's this one where the message
from m2 gets lost
yep that's another omission fault
does anybody remember from uh from day
one of class what we called it when
m2 lies
it's a fun one that's right it's a
byzantine fault
so at least we can categorize these into
the you know these four different kinds
of faults this is kind of a classic
way of categorizing faults the way that
i've done it here
and there are other reasonable ways to
do it and there are more
uh fine-grained categorizations that you
can make
but this setup that i have here where we
have four kinds of fault so mission
faults
crash faults timing faults byzantine
faults this is kind of a classic
taxonomy of faults that distributed
systems people have been using
for a long long time you know at least
since the 90s
um so let's try and define each of these
types of faults
a little bit more precisely
so in a crash fault
this is when a process
fails by halting
and this means it stops sending or
receiving any messages
so this is kind of interesting right i
didn't say that it had to stop having
internal events
i only said that it had to stop sending
and receiving messages but the thing is
that if you're some other process
and you want to know whether this
process is up or not
well if it stops sending and receiving
messages
then as far as you're concerned it has
crashed even if it's still
doing something by itself so as far as
any external observer is concerned
it's crashed if it stops sending and
receiving messages even though it still
may be doing some sort of computation on
its own
omission faults
are when a message is lost
and you could think of this if you want
as a process failing to send or receive
a single message
in a timing fault
uh a process responds
too late and there are some contexts in
which
too early
is also a concern this actually isn't
going to come up very much for us
because as we'll talk about in a minute
for the most part we're not going to be
thinking about timing faults
so this one is going to be less
interesting to us
and then finally a byzantine fault
a process behaves in an arbitrary way
or even a malicious way
okay
great question yeah so the question in
chat is how can an outside observer
process tell the difference between a
crash and an omission fault
yeah good question uh let's start to
talk about that a little so
let's say
let's say that we have some protocol
let's say i've implemented a protocol
call it protocol x
so recall what a protocol is from before
protocol is um
some set of rules for saying oh what
messages a process should send
in terms of what messages it's received
so let's say that we have protocol x
that i've implemented
and let's say that i'm going to say that
protocol x tolerates crash faults
and let's say that we have another
protocol called protocol y
and protocol y implements the same
behavior
as protocol x but we're going to say
protocol
y tolerates omission faults
so in other words protocol x is robust
to crash faults
it'll still work and let's say that
protocol y
is robust to a mission fault so it'll
still work even if messages get lost
so my question for you is this
does protocol y also tolerate crash
faults if we say that it tolerates
omission faults
does it also have to tolerate crash
faults what do you think
you
hmm so one response is not necessarily
i'm going to say that perhaps somewhat
surprisingly the answer is yes
why is that the case why why do we say
that this protocol that tolerates
omission faults also tolerates
crash faults well it turns out
that crash faults are the special case
of omission faults
where all of the messages
to and from a certain process get lost
so if you tolerate omission faults
which are faults where a message gets
lost
and i'm saying you know you could
tolerate any number of those right
then you also have to be able to
tolerate crash faults which are when
all of the messages you can think of it
as being all of the messages to and from
a particular process
getting lost so protocol that tolerates
omission faults
also has to tolerate crash faults and we
can draw a picture
uh illustrating how these different
categories of faults are nested so we
can say crash faults
are here and omission faults
are here so crash faults end up being a
subset
of omission faults
all right let's say that i also have uh
and you know i said earlier that timing
faults were one of the categories that
we care about but
um i'm actually going to leave out
timing faults for now
and then we'll come back to it
so
let's say that we have another protocol
protocol z
and protocol z implements the same
behavior as protocol x and protocol y
but it also tolerates byzantine faults
does protocol z also have to tolerate
omission faults
hmm i gotta know so what is a byzantine
fault a byzantine fault says that
a process could behave in an arbitrary
way right
or even a malicious way yeah so
basically anything could happen
so in fact
byzantine faults are a superset
of omission faults and the reason why is
that
a process that's exhibiting byzantine
behavior
could pretend to be having
these other kinds of faults right it
could be pretending to lose messages
or it could be pretending to crash so
if you can tolerate byzantine faults
then that's a superset of these other
fault classifications
then you can tolerate omission faults
and crash faults as well
so this protocol also has to tolerate
these other kinds of faults
so we've got byzantine faults which are
a super set of omission faults
which are a super set of crash faults
there's another the reason i left some
space in the middle here is because
there's actually another fault
classification that i kind of left out
before
so crash faults we said before a process
fails by halting but let me make that a
little bit more specific
so we'll say a process fails by halting
but
not everybody necessarily knows that
so let me try to differentiate crash
faults uh from
uh from a different category of fault
which i'll call fail stop
faults
so in a fail stop fault a process fails
by halting
and everyone knows
it crashed
in a crash fault that's not necessarily
the case
so in a crash fault we say that a
process fails by halting and not
everybody necessarily knows it
a fail stop fault you can think of it as
being like
the process sends out an announcement
right before crashing saying
i'm going to crash now and everybody
gets the announcement
so we can actually put this other
category in here
i didn't put that one in the list before
because
this one actually it's all these are
this one didn't come up actually when we
were classifying those faults that could
occur in that exchange of messages
between m1 and m2
so failstop is kind of an unrealistic
fault model
because in practice processes don't do
that right they don't announce that
they're about to crash
however this is still a useful category
to think about
because sometimes when you're designing
a system it's useful
to think about there being this notion
of fail stop fault
and we can kind of try to attempt to
fake
having this kind of fail stop fault by
having some sort of attempt to detect
failures
it turns out that those attempts to
detect failures can't be perfect
and so this is somewhat unrealistic but
i'm putting it here in the picture
because
sometimes you'll hear this notion of
faults disgust
yeah so there's a question about about
timing faults and the fact that i
left timing faults out of the picture
so why did i leave timing faults out of
the picture
does anyone this is kind of a hard
question so does anyone know why i left
timing faults out of the picture
it kind of it goes back to
near the beginning of the class when we
discussed network models and you recall
we talked about the asynchronous network
model
and how we were going to be spending
most of our time in the asynchronous
network model
so why do you think
given that context given that hint why
do you think that i left timing faults
out of this picture
patrick shared this quote flying is just
falling slowly
and i feel like that's apropos
yeah so we're in this asynchronous world
right
so my claim is that in an asynchronous
world
there are no timing faults
not really what i mean by that is
any kind of bug any kind of fault
it has to be relative to a specification
right if you say that there's a bug
in a piece of software then that means
that
some sort of spec that somebody had in
mind whether it's formal or informal
some sort of spec is being violated
whether that spec is just the
expectations in your head
or whether it's something that's written
down in a formal way
a bug is a violation of some sort of
specification so
if we had a specification that said
things shouldn't take more than a
certain amount of time
then we would they would we could have
timing faults right because
anything that violated that spec would
be a timing fault
but we don't have a specification like
that in the asynchronous network model
remember an asynchronous network is one
that where there's no
number n such that no message takes
longer than n
units of time to be delivered so in
other words messages can be arbitrarily
slow
so we're not going to be thinking about
timing faults because
in the asynchronous network model which
is where we're spending our time
timing faults really don't apply so i
haven't included them in this picture
here
it's a little bit of a head scratcher
isn't it
all right i think now is a good moment
to
pause and do our quiz question for today
and when we come back i think we'll have
time to talk about
one of my favorite distributed systems
uh thought experiments which is the two
generals problem all right so it's 4 19
let's return at 4 29 and i'll put up the
quiz question right now
you know what yeah i just realized
there's a typo
on the quiz question this should say a
good thing does happen
right here so have you already filled
out the quiz hopefully you
uh
knew what i really meant
all right fixed
oh
alright
all right one more minute
all right it's 4 29 so welcome back
okay so
before we get to the two generals
problem i just want to talk really
briefly
about um i didn't really i i
mentioned fault models but i didn't
really define what a fault model is
other than to tell you that it's
something that tells you which kinds of
faults can occur
so but now that we have all these
different nested classes of faults
defined
now i can somewhat more formally say
what a fault model is so we can say
a fault model
is a specification
that says
what kinds of faults
a system can exhibit
and this tells you
having trouble writing today this tells
you
uh
what kinds of faults
need to be tolerated
so if you're assuming the crash model
then that means that your system has to
be tolerant of crash faults
and if you're assuming the omission
model
you've got to be tolerant of omission
faults and crash faults
and if you're assuming the byzantine
fault model
you have to be tolerant of byzantine
faults and all those other kinds
so fault models are nested just like
classes of faults are
and as you move outward in this circle
the models get less and less forgiving
because more and more bad
things can happen in these models as we
move outwards
so which fault model do you think that
we're going to be talking about the most
in this class
that's right yeah we're going to focus
on the omission model
yeah somebody just says are we going to
focus on the byzantine model because
it's the least forgiving
i mean i wish uh but
that class would take more than one
quarter to teach
so we're going to be focusing on the
omission model
it's true that not as many bad things
can happen as in the byzantine model but
it's still
a model where an awful lot of bad things
can happen
and so it's still pretty hard to
implement
algorithms that assume the omission
model because those algorithms have to
tolerate a lot of bad things
in fact there are a lot of things that
we would like to be able to do
in distributed systems that are flat out
impossible to do
in the omission model
so as an illustration of that i want to
tell you about this classic thought
experiment in distributed computing
which
is called the two generals problem
so this is a really old thought
experiment it was originally described
in 1975
and in their setup in 1975
uh it was so it was published in a in a
paper um
that is pretty little known today
actually and then kind of
developed a kind of a life of its own
over the years but it's kind of funny
because in the original paper it wasn't
about two generals it was about two
groups of organized criminals
and somehow it became known as the two
generals problem in the intervening
years
not sure why anyway the idea is the
following
so let's say that we have two generals
let's say general alice and general bob
with their armies
and they're each encamped on a hill with
their armies
and in the valley in between
the enemy is encamped
so alice and bob know that neither one
of them on their own is strong enough to
attack the enemy
but if they work together they outnumber
the enemy so they'd like to both attack
the enemy at the same time
the only problem is
they're too far away to communicate
that so the only way for them to
communicate is
to send a messenger through the valley
where the enemy is encamped
and that messenger will sometimes be
captured by the enemy
and sometimes not and if a messenger is
captured then of course
the message that they're carrying gets
lost
so let's walk through what would happen
in the best case scenario
where no messages are lost and
everything goes fine
so let's say that general alice would
like to
mount an attack so alice sends a message
over to bob
and we can show that with a lan port
diagram if we want to
so ellis sends a message saying
attack it dawn
asking are you in
so let's say that bob gets the message
so at this point
bob knows that alice has proposed to
attack at dawn
well
should ellis go ahead and attack at this
point
that's right yeah so no she should not
because
she doesn't know that bob got the
message right she has no way of knowing
at this point whether her message got to
bob or not
so somebody just said alice needs an
acknowledgement yeah so bob should let
alice know that he got the message
so bob says okay i'm in attack tomorrow
at dawn
cool okay suppose that message gets
through
and it's received and delivered on
alice's side
now alice knows that bob got her message
is it safe now for alice to go ahead and
attack at dawn
the question is what time is it now
you're wondering if dawn has already
passed so maybe it's dawn the next day
right leaving
aside any concerns about whether dawn
has already happened
is it safe for alice to go ahead and
attack now that she's gotten the
acknowledgements from bob
and some folks are saying in chat no
it's not safe
she needs to let bob know that's right
bob doesn't know
that his acknowledgement got to alice
and he also knows that if alice doesn't
see an acknowledgment she won't attack
so bob can't attack right because he
only has three people
he can't be sure that alice is going to
attack too
so is this fixable well okay so somebody
said bob needs an acknowledgement that
alice got the acknowledgement
okay so what if alice sends another
message
to acknowledge the acknowledgement
okay it's on
does that solve the problem
yeah it's not looking good is it
no because alice doesn't know that that
message got through right
so bob could act that message as well
but of course he doesn't know that that
act was received
is there any way to fix this
smoke signals yeah let's assume that
alice and bob are too far apart to send
smoke signals
but yeah so in general
i think you're even though the the
suggestion might have been a joke
you're kind of on the right track in the
sense that
if there's some kind of side channel by
which alice and bob can communicate they
might be able to solve this problem
but if we're in a setting where
alice and bob can only communicate by
sending these messages through the
valley
it turns out that
in the omission model
it is impossible
for alice and bob
let's say alice or bob
to attack and
know for sure
that the other will attack it would
require sending this
infinite number of acts of acts of acts
of acts and so on
this boils down to one of the many
fundamental
impossibilities in distributed systems
and it applies in any situation
where you have two parties communicating
and
failures of communication can occur
so what are the practical workarounds to
this situation
other than if you had some other side
channel by which you could communicate
okay here's a suggestion stop after a
certain amount of acts and call it good
yeah so although it's impossible to
solve this problem it is possible for
the generals to
increase their confidence that the other
general will attack
so here's how that might go
one way to do this would be let's say
alice sends a whole bunch of messages
at regular intervals okay so say alice
keep sending messages that say attack at
dawn
so sooner or later say one gets through
and bob sends his ack
at that point alice has gotten the ack
so she can stop sending messages
so as time passes here on bob
bob can gradually grow more certain that
alice got this ack
because the longer that he goes without
getting a message from her
the more that he can be sure that she
actually stopped sending them on purpose
now it could be the case that she is in
fact still sending them and all of them
are getting lost
right
but we're assuming that the probability
of that is
gets lower as time goes on
so if the if the probability of all the
messages getting lost
as the number of messages sent increases
if the probability is low and gets lower
and lower as you send more
then after a while you know bob can be
reasonably sure over here if he's not
getting messages
he can be reasonably sure that she
actually did get this
and stopped sending the messages so
it's not a perfect solution but it's a
it's a solution that is good enough
for practical implementations often
so bob can be reasonably confident that
alice got the ack
and then the the attack could go forward
any other workarounds well
so one workaround is that
maybe before they went and camped out on
these hills
alice and bob coordinated with one
another
in some way so maybe alice and bob both
decided on their plan of attack
in person in some sort of discussion and
agreed on a plan
so that's what
philosophers and logicians call common
knowledge
so i guess i'll call this page
workarounds
so workaround number one
uh was this probabilistic argument
we'll call it probabilistic certainty um
work round two
common knowledge
so common knowledge just amounts to
alice and bob having planned out before
that they were going to attack at a
certain time so
we say that there's common knowledge of
some piece of information
let's call it uh let's say common
knowledge so
we say there's common knowledge of p
when
everyone knows p
everyone knows that everyone knows p
and so on infinitely everyone knows that
so common knowledge is this situation of
i can't write it all down here because
it's infinite um
so if there were some predetermined
attack time that was common knowledge
between alice and bob
that could work but the trouble is that
you cannot establish common knowledge
just by sending messages in a
distributed system with the omission
model so if they didn't set up that
knowledge in advance
there is no way for them to establish
common knowledge
later and that's one of the kind of most
interesting things to me about
distributed systems and this is
kind of beautiful fact that you can get
higher up in this hierarchy right
you can get to the point where everybody
knows a fact but then getting to the
point where everyone knows that everyone
knows that fact
takes more work and getting to the point
where everyone knows that everyone knows
that everyone knows and so on takes more
work so you can't ever get to the point
where
you get this whole infinite sequence
and i can refer you to some reading
material on that if you're interested
yeah so patrick points out
the way that we sketch this out with the
infinite acknowledgements
that you would need to have to solve
this problem
kind of looks like the definition of
common knowledge so
in you can think of what's going on here
is alice and bob attempting to establish
common knowledge
but they can't
okay so whenever i talk about the two
generals problem
somebody always brings up tcp
and they want to know if tcp solves the
problem uh
so let's really briefly talk about that
um so tcp gives you fifo delivery which
we've talked about a little bit and
it gives you reliable delivery as well
so
we're going to talk about the
implementation of reliable delivery uh
next time um but under tcp
if alice has to send a message to bob
she can keep sending it until she gets
an ack from bob right
and then she's done so tcp allows the
sender of a message to have
certainty that the message was received
but it still doesn't allow us to get
that common knowledge that would be
needed to solve this problem
it's kind of interesting actually
usually every time i teach this class
somebody says but what about tcp but
nobody brought it up this time
so i don't know maybe this is a group
that doesn't care as much about
networking
okay any questions about anything we
just talked about
all right i think that in the five
minutes that we have left
and now we're asking what about tcp
hopefully i address that question
um so in the five minutes that we have
left now i feel bad for depriving
y'all of answers to your questions on
our start of course survey so i thought
we would do a few of those
so you know if you have to bail right
now this isn't crucial information but
you know maybe it'll be fun okay so
questions for me about anything what's
kind of weird about this
this forum is that it seems to show me
the answers in an arbitrary order so
some of these we already talked about
um but let's just start at the top here
what is your favorite cat breed and what
breed is your cat
oh um so i like cats but i actually
don't know very much about cat breeds um
uh american short hair is that a cat
breed
um whatever my cat is it's like the most
typical boring cat breed and i don't
really have a
favorite cat breed i love all cats
all right i think this next one is might
might have been one that we talked about
last time about being worried about
future employment
i can't remember if we talked about this
one before but let me just say one thing
um so
the question here is i want to know
whether first of all whether i can find
a job but also whether i won't be
miserable in it
and so to tell you the truth
maybe you won't love the first job you
get maybe you won't love the second job
maybe you won't love the third job
life is long you have a long time to
figure it out what it what it is that
you want to do
and from every one of those experiences
whether it's good or bad you're going to
learn stuff from it and hopefully things
will be better the next time
so you know i don't think you have to
figure out exactly what you want to do
i didn't figure out that i wanted to do
distributed systems until just a few
years ago
and i'm 39 so i definitely didn't have
it figured out when i graduated from
undergrad
uh i didn't even take distributed
systems as an undergrad i don't think it
was offered at my school
but even if it had been i don't think i
would have taken it because i didn't
know that it was interesting back then
so you have a lot of time
also something that i'm trying to do is
uh put together a collection
of distributed systems related job
postings for you all so
i'm asking around for job postings from
people i know
and trying to find the ones that are
most relevant to what we do in this
class
both because i want you to see what's
out there and also because i want you to
see how the course is relevant to
the real world so hopefully i'll be able
to share that soon
all right so next question
if magic existed what type would you
like to cast i don't even know what this
question means to tell you the truth
um uh is there a kind of magic that
makes you good at gardening that's what
i want
all right how difficult will this course
be i think this is one that we talked
about earlier
since you stream on twitch do you do any
gaming yourself
so i don't stream any games
um but i do i used to not really play
games
but now that i have a toddler i
i play games with my toddler so if you
want recommendations for games that you
can play with a three-year-old i got
some of those
yoshi's crafted world is really fun um
we've been playing kirby star allies
which is another really cute
really easy platformer um
yeah i don't have personally like i
don't really set aside time to play
games but
um it's a fun thing to do with my kid
all right last question what parts of
cse130 are most relevant to this course
you know
i would like to answer this question but
unfortunately different different
versions of 130 are taught by different
people and cover different things
so i know some people looked at key
value stores when they took 130 and
other people didn't
for example so i don't really know what
to tell you on that one and i think that
the most relevant thing is not
necessarily any particular material
so much as it is experience doing a
large-scale systems programming project
with a group
so people who have taken 130
the key thing that they take away from
it is the experience of having done that
i think
uh less so that than any particular
skill or particular knowledge all right
we'll have to get to this next one about
underappreciated programming languages
next time it's 4 55. so let's wrap up
for today
and i will see you on thursday
take care
you